finally putting roe to rest that's the
focus of tonight's angle
today's oral arguments and the biggest
abortion case since casey versus planned
parenthood they were certainly
fascinating to listen to but they simply
confirmed what conservative legal
scholars have been arguing for nearly 50
years that the reasoning in row was pure
legal fiction
the court never should have waded into
the abortion wars
now perhaps the most revealing and
disturbing part of the argument came
during a discussion of starry decisis
the idea that court precedent here roe
versus wade should generally be
respected to preserve a measured
predictable development of legal
principles but left-wing justices and
their supporters in the press come on
they've largely abandoned the notion
that any textual provision of the u.s
constitution prohibits states from
preventing the killing of the unborn
at this point their main argument is
that roe has been on the books for a
long time and it's too late to do
anything about it well that's absurd the
notion that the american people are
stuck with a wicked decision
just for the sake of tradition goes
against everything the country stands
for
by that reasoning plessy versus ferguson
which allowed segregation for over 50
years would never have been overturned
by brown versus board of education
the mississippi solicitor general scott
stewart who was arguing in favor of his
state's 15-week abortion ban also argued
against bowing to president when much
has changed since roe including new
imaging technology
i think it's an advancement in knowledge
and concern about such things as uh
fetal pain what we know the child is
doing and looks like and is fully human
very early
40
of dead people
who if here touch their feet
the foot will recoil
there are spontaneous acts by dead brain
people
so i don't think
that a response
to
uh by a fetus necessarily proves
that there's a sensation of pain
or that there's consciousness
i mean how twisted how callous
and how uninformed
now by justice sotomayor's logic
i don't know
expected mothers shouldn't get too
excited when their baby kicks in the
womb after all the baby
could be dead and merely twitching now a
couple of the liberal justices contended
that overturning roe would destroy the
court's legitimacy
now justice breyer said that overruling
unnecessarily and under pressure would
just lead to the condemnation of the
court loss of confidence in the
judiciary the ability of the court to
exercise the judicial power and to
function just as a supreme court
dedicated to the rule of law justice
sonia sotomayor basically said the same
thing but she added that will this
institution survive the stench
that this creates in the public
perception that the constitution and
is not just you know being interpreted
as political acts by the court
well
justice sotomayor is right to worry
about a noxious stench
but it's the one the court created in
1973 when it robbed the states of their
right to determine this issue for
themselves
now in the words of the late great
antonin scalia
regardless of whether you think
prohibiting abortion is good or whether
you think prohibiting abortion is bad
the constitution does not say anything
about it it leaves it up to democratic
choice some states prohibited it some
states didn't
what roe versus way
wade said was that
no state can prohibit it that is simply
not in the constitution it was one of
those many things most things in the
world left a democratic choice
boy i wish he was there today
now the late uh judge bork was even more
blunt than scalia calling roe an act of
judicial imperialism
in other words inventing out of whole
cloth constitutional rights that the
framers just never intended
now the legal defenders of roe contend
that a woman's right to privacy and
bodily autonomy somehow trumps the right
of the life of the unborn child
exposing the illogical core of this
argument justice thomas asked whether
other actions beyond abortion are
similarly protected he said you know
there was a case out of south carolina
involving a woman who had been convicted
of criminal child neglect because she
ingested cocaine during pregnancy
and the woman arguing from the center
for reproductive rights said that those
issues aren't posed in this case well
she didn't answer the question
because doing so would collapse the
house of cards that roe was built upon
now the court in row and
in like the american left has always
used this viability argument to justify
depriving infants of their own
constitutional rights to life
in other words
they're not really persons under the
constitution unless they're viable
outside the womb
justice samuel alito smashed this entire
line of reasoning
and he basically said does a woman not
have the same interest that she had
before the viability of the fetus being
free of this pregnancy that she no
longer wants to continue
and again the a lawyer could not argue
the point she just said well viability
is a principled line
you get my point here
justice alito was right to raise this
the viability standard
it's just it's not what the court is
tasked with doing
uh the fetus has its own
individual rights well he's precisely
right
but
democrats are just the members of the
party of death
so basic logic and essential truths when
life begins doesn't matter them
abortion is their holy grail
and joe biden who likes calling himself
a catholic school kid he's too
unprincipled to take the stand that his
own faith requires
well that led justice brett kavanaugh at
the end of the oral arguments to raise
the issue that the liberal justices
conveniently avoided
he said there's also an interest in
fetal life that's at stake as well
and again biden solicitor general gave a
non-answer to kavanaugh because there is
no answer
the fact is neither the framers who
wrote the original constitution and the
bill of rights nor the drafters of the
14th amendment
ever intended to create a constitutional
right to abortion
indeed they would have found such a
concept to be barbarous and evil
the left claims to care about democracy
so let's let the people decide the
important questions presented by
abortion and if a court with a majority
of six republican appointees fails to
put road to rest
then it should expect a conservative-led
movement to shrink the court's power
oh
and would also mean adios to the
federalist society